so let's get a basic understanding of
the comparison test when we are trying
to decide whether a series is converging
or diverging so let's think of two
series so let's say that I have this
magenta series here it's an infinite
series from N equals 1 to infinity of a
sub N or speaking in generalities here
and let's say I have another one and
that's the series B sub n from N equals
1 to infinity and we know some things
about these series the first thing we
know is that all of the terms in these
series are non-negative so a sub N and V
sub n are greater than or equal to 0
which tells us that this that these are
these are going to diverge to positive
infinity or they're going to converge to
some to some finite value they're not
going to oscillate because you're not
going to have negative values here you
can't go to negative infinity because
you don't have negative values here now
let's say we also know that each of the
corresponding terms in the first series
are less than or equal to the
corresponding term in the second series
less than or equal to B sub N and once
again this is true for all the ends that
we care about so N equals 1 2 3 all the
way on and on and on so the comparison
test tells us that because this series
all the corresponding terms of this
series are less than the corresponding
terms here but they're greater than 0
that if this series converges the one
that's larger if this one converges when
the one that is smaller than it or guess
1 we think about is kind of bounded by
this 1 must also converge and I'm not
doing a formal proof here but hopefully
that gives you a little bit of intuition
so the comparison test tells us if if I
guess what in my brain the larger series
the one whose corresponding terms are at
least as large as the ones here if this
one converges if this one doesn't go
unbounded towards infinity it goes to
its sums to some finite value then that
tells us that the 1
that is in some ways I guess you say
smaller must also converge must also so
this one this one right over here
must also converge so that must also
converge so why is that useful and we'll
see this in future videos well if you
find if you're looking say you you have
your a sub n and you're like hey gee I
wish I could prove that it converges I
kind of have a gut feeling it converges
the comparison test tells us well just
find another series that is always that
whose corresponding terms are at least
as large as the corresponding terms here
and if you can prove that one converges
then you're good with this one and of
course it would only apply to the case
where your original series each of the
terms each of the terms are non-negative
now what if we want the other way around
what if you could prove that the magenta
series the smaller one and I guess I
could I could kind of put them in quotes
you know this one right over here is the
smaller the smaller I guess each of its
corresponding terms are smaller what if
you could prove this one diverges well
if this one diverges it's going to go
unbounded to infinity it's not going to
go to negative infinity all the terms
are positive it's not going to oscillate
it's not going to diverge because it
oscillates between two values once again
if it's oscillating between values that
wouldn't the only way you could do that
is if you had negative terms here so
this would kind of be unbounded towards
infinity well if this one is unbounded
each of these corresponding terms are
larger so this one must also be
unbounded so let's write that down
so the comparison test tells us if if
our smaller smaller series diverges if
this one diverges then the larger one
must also diverge then the month larger
one must also diverge and so once again
if you wanted to prove that this thing
right over here is going to diverge and
if you have a once again and you know
that all the B sub NS are greater than
or equal to zero and you want to prove
it diverges well maybe you could try to
find another series where each of the
corresponding terms are less than the
corresponding terms here and you could
prove this one diverges
then you would be all set and we're
going to start doing that in the
few videos